if we want to reconnect the social
fabric we have to rebuild relationships
in the most effective way to build
relationships is collaborate with
somebody else and solve a problem
don't talk up here and abstract get down
on the ground and solve the problem
hey and welcome this is the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special our guest today is
Carly Fiorina she's the head of the
unlocking potential foundation of course
2016 presidential candidate will talk
with Carly in just a second but first no
one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy who's got time for
all that traffic the parking the lugging
all your mail and packages it's a real
hassle and that's why you need stamps
calm it's one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and will save you money with
discounts you can't get even at the post
office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps calm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in the mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
com it's a no-brainer it saves you time
and it saves you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale with no
long term commitment just go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm and sir Shapiro carly
fiorina thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate it
it's great to be with you Ben thank you
for having me so for the vast majority
of people who are familiar with you I'm
sure they're familiar with you from the
2016 presidential campaign obviously had
a huge name profile before that you were
CEO of Hewlett Packard and you'd run for
Senate in California as well so what got
you from business into politics in the
first place well you know I kind of
realized that politicians and the
policies they pursue impact all of our
lives there were periods in my life
where I didn't vote at all
I thought politics wasn't for me and
then I realized actually politics
affects me it affects a lot of people
and I also think there's so much that's
broken about our politics I think as
George Washington observed in 1789 it's
about winning more than it's about
problem solving and I think the vitriol
and politics is really soul-crushing to
a lot of people and so I thought well
maybe I can make a positive contribution
and perhaps speak about it in a
different way and speak about a citizen
government which is what I think we were
meant to have well looking at the state
of politics now are you optimistic still
about that vision of getting into
politics because it seems like we're
getting more polarized there's sort of a
movement by Rod Dreher and others to
sort of move away from the political to
just saying listen nothing's getting
solved there let's move back into the
areas that you occupied beforehand
that's where the solutions are gonna get
done well I'm I'm kind of there at the
moment you know I think that first of
all we know this from our founders but
I've learned this in my life power
concentrated his power abused always
there's too much power concentrated in
Washington DC and what happens when
power gets concentrated especially in
big bureaucracies and let's face it
government's big bureaucracy is power
starts to serve itself preserve itself
and so problems don't get solved when
you're focused on keeping things the way
they are so the work that I do now is
really to lift up problem solvers
wherever they are in communities in
companies in organizations so that they
can be focused on solving the problems
right in front of them because they're
frustrated by the fact that the people
they thought were solving the problems
aren't really getting absolved okay so
let's talk about you jumping into
politics so I first became aware of you
because I didn't really read the
business section when I was you know 15
years ago but when when you first
started running for Senate in California
so what year was that 2008 10 2010 okay
so you're running for Senate in
California what prompted you to take out
a quixotic task like running for Senate
in California well as I told you I I
don't mind tough challenges I've been
attracted to tough challenges all my
life so that was a tough job
that was a tough challenge in a very
long shot but honestly I felt as though
there was nothing in the conversation in
the political conversation about the
people that I saw in California who
didn't think the way Barbara Boxer did
who were being harmed by the policies
that Barbara Boxer and Dianne Feinstein
and the Democrats in Sacramento were
pushing and I felt as though it was
important to have somebody with some
small shot to be able to stand up and
articulate what I thought were real life
realistic policies that actually work
that I know something about see one of
the reasons I think we were intended to
be a citizen government is politicians
don't know a lot about a lot of things
especially if they've been in politics
all their life I'm not saying they're
bad people there's some very good people
in politics but if all you've done is
run and win run and win run and win you
don't know a lot about what's going on
and yet you're making policies that
impact people tremendously and so
California's business environment was
getting harmed crushed by these policies
I happen to know something about it and
Barbara Boxer knew nothing about it and
that kind of ticked me off no turns out
Barbara Boxer knew very little about
anything but she wouldn't be the only
politician that way but I think so much
of politics just gets to be it's like
sports it's win-lose when my team my
team and we've turned into tribal team
players I'm on the d team so I always go
with the D I'm on the our team I always
go with the are that win lose never
solves problems although it may win
elections so after that taste of running
in 2010 what prompted you to think okay
2016 I really want more of this well
it's such a doubting question better I
talk to tons of politicians and I always
look at them and I say like this seems
horrible why would you want to do this
well you know there are things about it
that are
very hard but the voters make it great I
mean I have no regrets I loved talking
to citizens and one of the things that I
said the media once asked me was the
biggest surprise about running for
president I said the yawning chasm
between what citizens talk about and how
they talk about it and what the media
asks and how the media talks about it
there is a yawning chasm still which is
why it's so important that you do what
you do for example so why did I do that
I did it because once again I knew it
was a long shot I knew it was a tough
challenge but ours was intended to be a
citizen government and I know something
about big bureaucracies and I know what
makes them tick and I know what has to
happen to reform them in Washington is
one gigantic bureaucracy and it is a
system that seeks to preserve itself at
all costs
Republicans and Democrats alike I know
something about that I know how to
reform those systems and so I thought
well I think my voice can make a
contribution here and you famously made
a courageous stand in the middle of the
debates when you started talking about
Planned Parenthood openly and shots the
top of the polls what did it feel like
to go from nowhere to the top of the
polls in a matter of well wasn't exactly
the top of the polls but I think we did
get to something like 9 percent and so
that was a big change because when I
started less than 3 percent of the
electorate had ever heard of me I mean I
had no name ID you know I focused less
honestly on what the polls were saying
and more on what I was saying and the
Planned Parenthood that was the time of
course when the whole scandal about
selling body parts was coming out and
literally the media machine was saying
it wasn't true and of course it was true
and it's been demonstrably shown to be
true and that was just outrageous to me
outrageous because it is a crime against
humanity outrageous because it says
something terrible about the character
of our nation but also outrageous
because
here is something that's actually going
on that a whole bunch of people for
political reasons say it's not happening
and it was so you're in the middle of
this campaign you suddenly start to pick
up enormous steam and then Donald Trump
then candidate Trump decides to airmail
himself into the middle of the campaign
effectively and and insults you
personally I have to admit you know I I
didn't I was not a voter for President
Trump in 2016 I vote for any of the
candidates at the top of the tickets and
one of the reasons was because President
Trump routinely attacked people in ways
that I thought were unpalatable and it
wasn't just you obviously he accused
senator Cruz's father of killing JFK for
example does right he still does that
behavior continues right so how did you
how did you not get cynical about
politics given both his statements and
then the reaction to his statements
specifically targeting what you look
like well first let me say when when
Trump entered the campaign everything
changed instantaneously and you could
tell as a candidate the minute Trump
came down the escalator every question
became about him from the media every
question became about him on every
network because he was interesting he
was a celebrity
he drew eyeballs and so the whole
conversation shifted it's one of the
reasons I said what voters wanted to
talk about was so different than what
the media wanted to talk about and
Donald Trump knew that he was brilliant
at it and so okay give me the media
attention he said and it worked
regarding president Trump's comments
about me and I actually tell that story
in this book but gee president Trump
isn't the first man who ever said
something about my looks either positive
or negative women's looks are discussed
as a way of demeaning or dismissing them
it's happened to me all my life so when
it first happened it was just kind of
like oh go here we go again my staff was
stunned and I just said we'll we'll find
a time to deal with it and so I finally
dealt with it in that debate
people were shocked that he said it in a
presidential campaign but in fairness
he's not the only man or the first man
to have said things like that were you
perturbed though by the reaction of
primary voters that they that they
looked at that and they didn't find that
offensive enough to be even close to
disqualifying obviously when he wins the
nomination then goes on to become
presidents of the United States well I
find it disturbing I do I find it
disturbing that we have come to accept a
level of discourse and behavior that
should be unacceptable
I don't think Trump is necessarily
because of this he may be the result of
it but the level of vitriol Conflict
insult that we now think of as routine
in civil discourse should not be
acceptable in this nation and it worries
me because and that's what I meant when
I said earlier politics somehow the way
we conduct politics is it has infected
everything part of that is social media
people will say things on social media
that they would never say to your face
and yet we've just sort of come to think
that's okay it's not okay so moving
forward what do you make of President
Trump so now you know obviously is the
president how do you create his
performance as president well let me say
a couple things first
Republicans have rightly criticized
Democrats for assassinating someone's
character because they don't agree with
them
remember John McCain was a racist Mitt
Romney was a misogynist neither men or
either one of those things it's wrong to
assassinate someone's character because
you disagree with something but it's
equally wrong to defend someone's
character just because you happen to
agree with some of their policies I
think Donald Trump is a nerd
painter so he focuses on himself and a
leader focuses on those they serve I
think Donald Trump is a politician so he
focuses on winning a leader focuses on
problem solving I think a leader
understands that how you do things
matters hugely it matters as much as
what you do because how you do things
build support or not it builds character
or not it lifts people up or not and
while I agree with some of the things
Donald Trump does I rarely agree with
how he does any of them
so moving forward to 2020 and is the
hard question obviously do you plan on
voting for him in 2020 I don't know so
what would he have to do in order to win
your vote in 2020 they don't traffic and
hypotheticals you've never have won't
now okay so looking at the future of the
Republican Party then you know I I as
I've said did not vote for any of the
top candidates in 2016 many of my chief
worries about President Trump as
president involved him alienating young
voters particularly yeah my generation
is very anti Trump that's that's true
for many young Republicans as well as
many young Democrats what do you see is
the future of the Republican Party the
theory of the media is that it's a
demographically shrinking base that that
base will continue to shrink
demographically and that the future of
the Republican Party is basically there
is no future the Democratic Party is
going to win from here so it's her today
where do you see the Republican Party
going do you still consider yourself a
member of the Republican Party well I
think that depends on people who call
themselves conservatives and Republicans
I really do so for example when people
who are Republicans say that it is the
duty of Republicans to pledge loyalty to
President Trump that doesn't bode well
for the future of the party this is
America we don't pledge loyalty to a
president not in this country in this
country a citizen is sovereign and a
president has to earn our respect so I
think it depends when there are
constitutional principles at stake and
yet those get swept aside
because oh my gosh we have to stand with
President Trump because the Democrats
are bad I don't think that bodes well
for the future of the Republican Party I
mean let's just take the Muller report
I've read every single word of it there
are real constitutional principles at
stake there and so for people to say oh
just never mind I don't think that bodes
well for the future the Republican Party
something asked you in depth about is
since you've read them all are important
since the hot topic of the moment it
looks like it's going to be unfolding
the consequences of it over the next
couple of months what do you think ought
to happen so my brief take on the Mullen
report is that it has an enormous amount
of both embarrassing and terrible
behavior by the President of the United
States as of wire I didn't see anything
that rises to the level of criminal
obstruction of justice
obviously William bar felt the same
Robert Muller had the capacity to rule
on that he didn't he sort of kicked it
over do you think number one that there
I didn't see more evidence of collusion
than was already there I didn't see
criminal collusion what was your overall
assessment of the Mullen report and what
ought to happen from here well first let
me say one of the things I learned in my
brief time in law school is that lawyers
can disagree and apparently a lot of
lawyers disagree about this I'm not a
lawyer but as a citizen reading this
report I found the report first of all
you're right and Muller is very clear in
the room this report that he sets a very
high bar it's called criminal conduct
that's a very high bar to have to clear
I would also say the report is carefully
and precisely written I would say that
Trump is not exonerated I would also say
Trump did not fully cooperate but more
to the point the Russian interference
that volume of the report is stunning
and shocking and the fact that we are
not having a conversation in this
country about how to prevent that from
happening again
is really dereliction of duty I think
honestly
and the fact that both Republicans and
Democrats in fairness have taken that as
a political issue it's not a political
issue
the sweeping systemic I'm quoting as you
know the sweeping systemic interference
in our elections by the Russians is now
a political football and it should not
be do you remember when Republicans were
so upset because President Obama
whispered to President Medvedev and said
I'll have more flexibility after the
election and Republicans went up in arms
oh my gosh of course the FBI had to
investigate the hints that they were
given there was a lot there and we
should be shocked by what has been
uncovered and alarmed and I would also
say that in volume two I accept I'm not
a lawyer it wasn't criminal conduct but
this is not the way a president of the
United States and his staff should be
behaving and my question is if it were
democrat doing this what would
Republicans be saying see here's the
thing about principles they're sometimes
inconvenient and if a principle is right
when it's a Democrat in the White House
then that principle remains right when a
Republican is in the White House and I
think the Republican Party the Democrat
Party too has to kind of get focused on
what are our principles and I think our
principles as a conservative are power
concentrated is power abused
decision-making has to be dispersed huge
bureaucracies have to be reformed people
closest to the problem know best how to
solve them and that definitely doesn't
mean people in Washington DC it means
people in cities and communities and
families and businesses and we are a
long way from those principles so in a
second I want to ask you to turn to the
Democratic Party and give your diagnosis
there since you've given your diagnosis
the Republican Party but first
communication in a marriage is key but
if we're honest some things are kind of
rough to discuss with our spouse or with
anyone for that matter one of those
things is sex even though 52% of dudes
over the age of 40 and 26 percent under
erectile dysfunction studies show that
70% of men who experience eg don't get
treated for it and that's where our
friends at Roman come in thankfully
Roman created an easy way to get checked
out by a doctor and get treated for IDI
online with Roman you can get medical
care for 80 if appropriate from the
comfort and privacy of your own home you
can handle everything online in a
convenient discreet manner getting
started it's actually really simple
just go to get Roman comm slash been
complete an online visit if your doctor
decides that treatment would be
appropriate they can prescribe genuine
medication it can be delivered in
discreet packaging directly to your door
with free two-day shipping guys go talk
to the doctor reptile dysfunction can be
tough to tackle it's really important to
get it checked out with Roman it's easy
to connect with the doctor just go to
get Roman comm / Ben to get a free
online visit and free two-day shipping
that is get Roman comm / Ben for a free
visit to get started g-e-t our oma n.com
/ Ben get Roman comm / Ben alright so
let's talk about the the Democratic
party on the other side of the aisle so
suffice it to say with a lot of your
critiques of the Republican Party
obviously I'm deeply worried about
people who are willing to go along with
bad behavior simply in the name of
getting a win I do think that there are
a lot of people who obviously I would
assume you agree with those who back
President Trump not because of his worse
aspects but because they feel they're
getting what they want in terms of
policy and they are pragmatist when it
comes to okay there's only one guy on
the ticket in front of me he's the
person I got a vote for absolutely
absolutely and and then they look at the
Democratic Party and they say all these
people had to do was be sane and that's
not a thing that seems to be happening
what's your diagnosis of the of the
Democratic Party and who do you think is
is best position inside the Democratic
Party I know you're not in the
speculation but who are you thing are
the top candidates in the Democratic
Party position for 2020 so I think the
Democrats have taken the easiest
possible route and rather than really be
introspective about why they lost who
they're missing who they're not
appealing to anymore because of their
rabid identity politics they've taken
the easy way out and they've said it's
all Trump it's all Trump it's all Trump
and it's not all Trump Democrats have
control
commuted to this climate as I said
earlier I think in a way Trump is the
result of a long decline in our
political discourse not the cause of it
and Democrats have been unbelievably
insulting and assassinating people's
character because they didn't agree with
them and now they just say Trump is bad
Trump is bad everything Trump does is
bad and everything has become a partisan
football and of course they go further
and further and further and further to
the left and so if Bernie Sanders is
their nominee Trump will win and a
landslide
if Elizabeth Warren is their nominee
Trump will win in a landslide I still
think we should call out bad behavior
when we see it I still think we should
stand up for constitutional principles
but when faced with the choice between
policies that will ruin this country and
policies that generally speaking or
working for this country people are
gonna vote for Trump so I think the
question for the Democrats the question
for someone like Joe Biden who I think
many people would say maybe has the best
shot of beating Trump because he appeals
to some of the same constituents that
took Trump over the top against Hillary
Clinton Biden has to survive a Democrat
primary and we'll see we'll see so far
you know apologizing endlessly for
getting into someone's personal space
wasn't a strong story so looking at sort
of the problems that face the United
States there seems to be a couple of
broad consensus items that I think I
personally believe are incorrect but
seem to have become common wisdom some
of those broad consensus items seems to
be that the that there is a large group
of Americans who are being economically
left behind thanks to income inequality
and that the only way to rectify that
imbalance is either through government
redistribution ISM or through
restrictions on trade what do you make
of the argument that the rising
population of the left and the right are
driven by the idea that major
corporations have been outsourcing that
that communities are being left empty
and what do you think is the salut
into that if any see to me this question
is a classic example of problems being
placed in the wrong place so why do
people say income inequality
redistribution trade because those are
federal solutions yes there are people
being left behind unlocking potential
foundation does a lot of work in
communities there are structural
impediments Washington DC is the most
rapidly gentrifying city in the nation
and as a result people who have lived
there all their lives can no longer
afford to live there if you live in a
neighborhood that like Ward 8 in DC your
life expectancy is 37 years less than 10
miles away because there's an inadequate
medical care because there's not as
healthy food options all of these things
have been building up for a very very
very long time so it's naive for us to
say actually there is no problem
everyone everyone is doing better
everyone isn't doing better on the other
hand the solution to that is not federal
it's not I mean trade policy could help
in certain ways redistribution who do
you give the money to for what these are
problems that require collaboration at
the community level this is the work my
foundation does to bring people together
in a community lift leaders up not based
on their position or their title but
their ability to solve a problem and one
of the things I see happening all across
this country is people are so sick of
politics they're so sick of something
nothing happening that they're saying
you know what we're gonna have to kind
of buckle down and do something with
this problem because we actually know
something about it it impacts us not
everything is gonna get fixed in
Washington DC there are some federal
solutions that are required but most
things actually and this is the genius
of our founders most things actually get
solved a little closer at all so when we
talk about solving things closer to home
yeah I've written extensively about the
breakdown of the social fabric
my new book is all about that obviously
people like Tim Carney have talked in
there but he has a book called alienated
America talking about the disintegration
of the social fabric how is the social
fabric rebuilt because it seems like
without that social fabric people are
going to look more and more to
government including the federal
government for solutions that used to be
solved on a community level and my
solution has largely been you need to
reengage not only with the ideas of the
founding but also with your religious
roots and no Tim Carney sort of believes
the same thing that with the death of
church particularly the middle of
country a lot of the social fabric has
disintegrated how do you think that
social fabric can be rebuilt people have
to connect with each other I know it
sounds so basic but church used to be a
place where people connected with one
another people have to connect with one
another and solve problems it's amazing
what happens when people decide I'm
gonna collaborate with you and solve a
problem it could be a simple problem it
could be a complicated problem we have
to stop looking up there we have to
reconnect with one another the work that
we do in my foundation we work with all
kinds of people we never ask what's your
political party what are your political
beliefs what's your religious
affiliation we never ask instead what we
do is what problem do you want to focus
on what problem do you want to solve and
when people get focused on a problem
that impacts more than them then they
start reaching out to others if we want
to reconnect the social fabric we have
to rebuild relationships in the most
effective way to build relationships
I've learned this over and over and over
let's collaborate with somebody else and
solve a problem
don't talk up here in abstract get down
on the ground and solve a problem and it
turns out people kind of like doing that
and they figure out okay you and I look
different we may think different we're a
different generation but we can actually
get along and get something done so you
mentioned a little bit earlier that you
do think that there are certain areas
where federal solutions are available so
what are some of the federal solutions
that you think ought to be applied and
that are not currently being applied
well you mentioned
trade I mean trade policy absolutely
impacts people in all kinds of ways I
don't happen to be a big fan of tariffs
because I think demonstrably they harm
our consumers and our businesses more
than they harm the trading partners
we're trying to punish but that's
clearly an answer I think there's no
question that the deregulatory movement
that the Trump administration is led has
had a wonderful effect on the economy
the more confidence businesses of all
sizes have in the economy and that
confidence in part comes from their
knowing that you know if I see an
opportunity I can go after it if I see
someone I want to hire I can hire them
without being burdened by a whole set of
things coming down the pike that I can't
afford all those things help my point
however is that I think government so
often gets in the way more than it
solves a problem and I also think that
politicians don't actually focus on
solving problems they focus on winning
and the truth is here's the dirty truth
about politics unresolved problems win
elections how long have we been talking
about the same problems how long have we
been talking about immigration 50 years
how long have we been talking about care
of veterans how long have we been
talking about debts and deficits how
long have we been talking about
government reform we've been talking
about those things forever how long have
we been talking about abortion forever
and the truth is having those things
unresolved and getting people all riled
up about them wins elections we've seen
it over and over again if politicians
aren't going to role model problem
solving and I don't think they have for
a very long time I think citizens are
gonna have to and what I know and what I
say in this book is we're actually all
meant for problem solving we have the
potential to problem solve and it's very
fulfilling what do we do it do you think
the American people are ever going to
get the hint about
and vote this way in other words the
American people we like to make a lot of
overtures about problem-solving and
getting together and fixing all of these
things and then we tend to vote for the
most entertaining politicians the people
who tell us what we want to hear the
people who pander to us the people who
yell at each other the loudest and
that's not unique to President Trump
this existed long before President Trump
so do you think that we ever get the
hint or do you think that basically what
we end up with is you know to come full
circle where we ended up at the
beginning that we end up with more and
more people disengaging from politics I
used to believe pretty strongly that the
people who are going to be most involved
in saving the country were the people
who are politically aware I'm not so
sure that's the case anymore I think
that the people who may save the country
are the people who are least politically
aware because they were focused and
checked out Fred exactly the people who
have decided you know what I can't focus
on all this noise out here instead I'm
going to focus on the stuff that I can
do right in front of me do you think the
American people clue into this or do you
think that basically we have a widening
ever yawning gap between the political
class and everybody else well what I see
happening in communities yes I do think
people are cluing into it but I also
think that we have to be you know one of
those things that I think you have to do
to solve a problem is be clear-eyed
about what the current state is so I
mentioned George Washington 1789 the
trouble with political parties they will
come to care only about winning the
system is designed to win on both sides
political parties have put together a
system that narrows choices quickly that
supports people who are already in
office that provides benefits to the
folks who are already in politics and
makes it very difficult for people who
aren't in politics so if you doubt that
think about what the system produced and
has produced honestly in the United
States of America this political system
both parties produces Hillary Clinton
versus Donald Trump this is the best we
can do I think not I think not so
eventually I think we're going to have
to figure out that political parties are
not always operating
in citizens best interest they're
operating in their own interest and
they're operating in the interests of
people who are trying to win elections
but in the meantime I think we gotta
solve the problems right in front of us
and quit looking to Washington to do it
for us and that means as well by the way
role modeling the behavior that
eventually we want out of our elected
officials instead of parroting their
behavior so in one second I want to ask
you about the euro is a publicly facing
woman in the business world but first
its spring the time of year when seeds
grow into flowers and you grow up or at
least you should financially your family
needs protection if something happens to
you and that means you need life
insurance thankfully policy genius makes
it easy to get that financial security
without any of the growing pains policy
genius is the easy way to buy life
insurance online in just two minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find your best price once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape no
Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached and policy genius
doesn't just simplify life insurance
they also make it easy to compare and
buy home insurance and auto insurance
and disability insurance so the next
time you stop to smell the roses pull
out your phone head on over to policy
genius comm policy genius spring is here
so kick it off by nipping life insurance
in the bud be a responsible human a
responsible adult make sure that your
family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you
and when you're doing life insurance
thing you can also do home insurance all
the different kinds of insurance go
check them out they make it really easy
policy genius.com that's policy genius
com go check them out right now policy
genius com okay so let's talk about what
it was like to be CEO of HP what sort of
public requirements do you think we're
different maybe because you're a woman
then there would have been for a male
CEO in the same position did you feel
that there were certain burdens that you
had to carry just publicly your
challenges that you had to face in that
role that if you've been a man you would
have had to face I don't I wouldn't use
the term requirements but what I would
say is the scrutiny is different the
criticism is different so for example
when I took the job I was very focused
on the fact that this was a great
company that had lost its way we'd
missed nine quarters in a row we were
losing market share profit
ability was deteriorating we had to fix
some things and so I was ready on the
day of my announcement to speak to the
press about those things why this was
still a great company but we needed to
make some fundamental changes to restore
our innovative spirit and what did the
press want to talk about oh my gosh or a
woman the editor of the most widely read
business publication at the time the
very first question I was asked was what
designer major suit when I was
presidential candidate my campaign was
routinely asked what kind of shoes I was
wearing so these are things that men
simply don't have to deal with and they
are a distraction the other thing that I
would say is I think that there is an
understanding between men of the
necessity for respect and how it's
important to give another man respect
I'm not sure that understanding exists
where women are concerned and so people
will talk in terms about women that they
would never use for men now the reason I
say I don't think it was a different
requirement I was a chief executive
officer of publicly traded company and
my job was just the same as any other
CEOs I needed to worry about our
customers our employees the communities
in which we lived and worked our
shareholders we had a massive
transformation that we needed to take
that company through and so it was my
job not to let all this noise distract
me but there's a lot of noise and it
takes energy not to be distracted by it
so what were your strategies for
forgetting over that I mean I know that
you know just being in the public eye
even in what I do the amount of flack
that I take which is nothing compared to
the mount of flak that you've taken over
your career can be extraordinarily
draining just on a personal level how
did you deal with that on a personal
level being attacked so much being the
public eye so much being under scrutiny
so much I ignored it I ignore it all
it's one of the things I say in this
book if you can't get over being
criticized you will never fulfill your
potential if you can't get over being
criticized you will never lead you will
never change the order of things for the
better you will never actually solve the
problem
because criticism is the price whether
you're a man whether you're a woman
whether you're different whether you
look like everyone else criticism is
always the price yes the criticism of me
as a woman who's maybe different gee I
don't like her suit I don't like her
hair on the other hand the fact that
there's criticism that accompanies every
leader and by the way leader is not
about your position or your title is
about whether you're solving a problem
and changing the order of things for the
better
criticism is the price and so I learned
very early on I got criticized a lot in
her early in my career who does she
think she is why is she doing that my
gosh people have been trying to solve
that problem for ever why does she think
she can do it
I learned to tune it out that doesn't
mean by the way that I didn't seek
feedback those feedback is very
important and feedback comes from people
who actually care about what you're
trying to do and they maybe care about
you but criticism is just noise from
people standing on the sidelines who
don't have the job that you have and
don't have the responsibilities that you
do whatever your job is and whatever
your responsibilities are so what's your
social media strategy social media is
just criticism that's right so whatever
exactly right so first of all you have
to put it in perspective and I know it's
very difficult again social media is one
of the reasons I wrote this book because
if you think about it people are growing
up in an environment they're trying to
find their way in an environment where
criticism is omnipresent
where criticism is unbelievably intense
cruel even where we have national
debates and dialogues at the highest
levels of politics that kind of feel
like vitriolic cruel superficial
criticism that's an incredible
environment to have to find your way in
and yet it means that when you get all
that stuff you got to put it in
perspective and you have to realize if
you're doing something worthwhile if
you're solving a problem if you're
providing another point of view 85% of
what you're gonna get is criticism okay
that's where
so I want to ask you about you know you
mentioned your education earlier that
the loss of the fact that you dropped
out of law school that you ended up
going for an MBA so what are your
thoughts on people who are looking at a
career path and thinking about College
Law School MBA and what do you think our
colleges are worth at this point it's
obviously there's big controversy over
whether everybody's you go to college
for free or whether we should pay five
hundred thousand dollars to get our kids
into Crew at USC yeah
wow what a create that talk about a
terrible lesson for those kids not to
mention for society at large so first
what I say to people and I say in this
book is don't get hung up on the plan I
see so many people honestly and I've
seen it all throughout my career who
have so much potential but they get on a
plan okay I'm gonna graduate from Moscow
and then I need to make this much money
and then I need to be a partner in this
firm and then I need to get marry and
then I need to have somebody give it
they have all these things that have to
happen for their plan to come true and
they miss so many opportunities along
the way
ambition is fine but if you get so hung
up on a particular destination I have to
be here by this point if I'm not here by
this point it's over that's a real dead
end because what happens to people is
either they get there and it isn't what
they thought or they sell so much of
their soul to get there they give up so
much to get there but by the time
they're there they're not at all who
they should be where they never get
there at all and they're devastated and
none of those outcomes are good so yes
be ambitious but see the opportunities
around you and sometimes the
opportunities around you might cause you
to take a detour and it won't be fatal
it might be exactly where you're meant
to go so what's the contrast between you
know following the opportunity and the
soak up kind of follow your bliss
movement in the 1960s you talked about
how you were looking for a self
fulfillment when you dropped out of law
school this wasn't something he felt was
fulfilling for me I had a similar
experience when I finished law school I
worked for a major law firm for about
ten months I thought it was the worst
thing ever I dropped out I went to work
for one-third the pay at a different
company and that started me on a
different career track and I
I very much encourage people to do that
sort of thing but how do you know the
difference between when you're when
you're dropping something that you're
doing in search of another opportunity
and when you're dropping something that
you're doing in favor of something
stupid because you do see this to you
know people who have a plan and then
they decide to follow their dream and it
turns out that their dream is to finger
paint how do you how exactly do you do
distinguish well first of all it would
never have occurred to me to say I was
dropping out of law school for
self-fulfillment it's not how I thought
about it and I realized it was somewhat
tongue-in-cheek in the 60s and all that
but I think therein lies the truth if
you hate something you're going to be
bad at it I mean it's just human nature
if you hate something you're going to be
bad at it
I think the difference between dropping
something you hate and following an
opportunity versus finger painting is
are you actually wanting to be excellent
are you prepared to work hard are you
trying to make a positive difference
working hard and being excellent is
really key it's not just key to success
it's actually key to fulfillment and so
wherever a path takes someone the
question I always ask them is do you
like what you do are you learning are
you making contribution are you working
hard are you doing the best job again
and if the answer to all those five
questions is yes yes yes yes then you're
probably on the right path so here's a
question that is very often asked to
females not as often as two males
probably should be asked two men more
often but how did you balance career
with family life now this is obviously
something that my own wife struggles
with is she as I've said she's she's a
doctor that means she's been basically
in medical school since we met which is
now 11 years coming up in July we'll be
married she's finally finishing
residency thank God in in two months but
she's taken time off one when we had
kids she took six months off our first
kid took about three months off her
second kid she's planning on working
part-time after she's done because she's
looking for particular balance how do
you think it's important to draw a
balance between what you're doing in
terms of family life and what you're
seeking in terms of career because there
is a prevailing view out there that
women can have it all and they're only
four hours in a day and I wonder how
much that's true well I think first of
all there is no silver bullet there is
no magic answer and there is no cookie
cutter answer either I sort of face this
when I realized that something very
fundamental how each of us spend our
time becomes our life and so therefore
we have to own the choice of how am I
going to spend my time because how we
spend it becomes our life and so I got
very intentional very deliberate about
how do I spend my time and the
revelation for me when as I was when I
realized whatever choice I make someone
will be unhappy whatever a choice I make
someone will be unhappy because someone
always wants more if you're focused on
work your family wants more if you're
focused on family your work once more
and so that also is something I think we
have to learn to live with but when I
say I'm deliberate and intentional I
began a process of looking at how am i
spending my time in a week how am i
spending my time in a month how am i
spending my time in a year and then to
look back at it and say are these the
choices that I think I should be making
and each one of us has to make that
choice there is no one-size-fits-all and
there is no silver bullet you have to
own those choices because it becomes
your life and you have to realize not
everyone will be happy but that's part
of the price - do you think that the
media have have sort of pervade a
mythical view of what of what the
balance can be in other words it seems
like there's an Instagram view that you
can work full-time at a job spend 12
hours a day with your children vacation
every month and all of this somehow
works out perfectly if you watch TV
there seems to be very little struggle
to draw that balance it's it's basically
I'm a high-powered lawyer and I work
full time but I also am there for every
one of my kids baseball games and so
well I'm not sure that that's just the
case I feel like there's what what
that's leading to in many ways is women
sometimes putting off maybe I mean
statistically women are putting off
marriage they're putting off
childbearing they're putting off child
until later in time because they've been
told by a media that that career ought
to come first when in reality maybe it
should for for certain women but it's
not invariable there is a ticking clock
on one end when it comes to family and
there's not a ticking clock necessarily
when it comes to career what do you
think the media's role is in drawing
sort of a model for for how women should
pursue career well I do think that I
give women maybe a little more credit
for thinking for themselves but I do
acknowledge your point that so much of
what we see on television and in social
media is just a fantasy
it's a fantasy I mean so much of social
media is a complete fantasy how much
time do people spend curating their
Instagram photos that's a fantasy and
it's not only a fantasy it's a
superficial fantasy and so part again
part of I think what people have to deal
with in this environment and part of the
reason I wrote this book now is to say
understand what all this is it's
entertainment
maybe it's a little bit of propaganda
frequently it's driven by a business
incentive to make money on the part of
the media so therefore they want people
to watch now who wants to watch about
real life isn't it easier to watch about
some fantastic
you know fantasy about how everything
can be but I think that life is always
trade-offs it is for men too and there
are a lot of men in my father's
generation who got to the end of their
careers and said oh my gosh what have I
missed
how much have I missed and they
regretted that far more than they
thought about the corner office they
attained so in your book find your way I
mean it covers an enormous amount of
ground you also talk about sort of being
driven and focused with regard to
relationships so you talk about this
specifically with regard your first
husband I was wondering if you could
could tell that story well my first
husband was a mistake but
you know without getting into all the
sordid details let's just say he
betrayed my trust in very significant
ways and so I had to come to grips with
that and say this isn't gonna work I
wasn't the first person to do that but
it felt incredibly difficult and
dramatic to me and fortunately I met the
love of my life and my soul mate and 37
years later here we are so life worked
out but I think often about what might
have happened to me had I not had the
courage to make that choice
courage features prominently in a
fulfilling life or a successful life or
an impactful life and what ends up
happening to so many of us is it is our
fears that hold us back and most of
those fears are kind of silly I mean my
fear honestly with my husband my my
first husband my mother never really
liked him was oh no my parents are gonna
say I told you so
Wow silly is that and yet how often do
people get held up by I'm afraid I'm
gonna make a mistake of course we all do
I'm afraid I'm gonna get criticized
I'm afraid I'm gonna look foolish I'm
afraid my likes will don't go down all
those are such stupid fears and so
getting over those fears being
courageous is a huge part of an
impactful productive fulfilling
successful life so I want to get back to
your tips that you have in your book
find your way which is really a terrific
book in in a little while I want to go
back to the very beginning for people
who don't know your whole story so your
story is really fascinating because it
had a lot of ups and downs you talk in
your book find your way about your story
about the fact that your parents
expected you to go to law school and you
decided not to go to law school and then
somehow you end up going from secretary
to CEO of hewlett-packard so can you
tell that story about why didn't you
decide to go to law school he started
yeah I started because I was one of
those kids who was a parent pleaser
I was a middle child I was
one who is never gonna disappoint my
parents expectations for me weighed very
heavy on me and so I lived through their
expectations by the way there are a lot
of people who live for other people's
expectations and so I go off to law
school and I just hate it and then I
realize I have to make a choice I'm
either gonna pursue something that I
truly hate and please my parents or I'm
gonna please myself and find my own way
and so I dropped out and that was an
incredibly difficult decision I wasn't a
quitter I wasn't the person who was
gonna drop out but now I have to go make
a living and so I had put myself through
school as an undergraduate as a
temporary secretary in local businesses
and so I went back to work full-time
typing and filing and answering the
phones I mean we don't really even have
those positions anymore we keyboard we
don't type but that's what I did and I
was grateful for that job I really was I
typed and filed and answered the phones
for a nine-person real estate firm it
was a dead-end job man but it paid the
rent and maybe six months into that job
two men came up to my desk they worked
there and they said we've been watching
you you do such a good job you're so
focused maybe you want to know about
what we do and that was my first
introduction to business I had never
thought about business I ran away to
Italy to teach English for a year you
can imagine my parents are really
concerned and finally I buckle down and
get an MBA and I land in an entry-level
position in a vast company with
literally 1 million employees and I'm at
the bottom of the totem pole I didn't
have a plan to get ahead I didn't think
I would make it a year but what I saw
were problems everywhere that just
festered that everybody talked about but
nobody did anything about and I saw
people impacted by those problems who
actually knew a lot about them so I
started working with people and solving
problems and what I figured out is if
you solve problems and change the order
of things for the better and produce
results people pay attention
and then other opportunities came along
literally that is the story of my life
so how do you get from you know working
at the lowest level at 1 million person
company to being the head of a company
that hires hundreds of thousands of
people I ran two problems I know it
sounds so basic but that's the truth I
ran two problems I always took the
challenging jobs cuz I figured out I
like challenge I liked solving difficult
problems that everybody else is saying
whoo stay away from those problems and
the reason I liked it so much is because
everywhere I went I found people who
knew something about the problem people
closest to the problem know best how to
solve it it's just there so often not
asked and so I would ask people and
they'd always have good ideas and then
we've worked together and I found I
loved that I loved the teamwork of it I
love the collaboration of it I like the
intellectual challenge of it and when
problems get solved when things get
better I guarantee you other
opportunities come along and they always
did and I wasn't afraid to say okay I'll
take on that challenge so your story is
actually somewhat like my own mother's
my mom started off as an education major
at she went to Northwestern than Boston
University and she started off as a
secretary to company she ended up
becoming vice president of that company
and I'd be curious to get your thoughts
on what it was like to be a woman
working at that time you know there's a
lot of talk now about sexism in the
business world and about the the
so-called glass ceiling in the business
world what were your experiences with
being a working woman you know a couple
of decades ago when apparently there was
you know allegations of a lot more of
that kind of sexist abuse in the
workplace obviously now we still
experience people who suggest that
that's a prevalent problem well both are
true it was then and it is now that's
just a fact and let me quickly say most
people are not bad people there are some
bad people who engage in bad behavior
and that behavior has to be confronted
but most people are maybe thoughtless or
careless or clueless or maybe they're
afraid so I'll give you three examples
the first one I already mentioned two
men come to my desk and take a chance on
me and say you can do more and they
encouraged me to go on my first client
meeting ever at that vast company called
AT&T was held in a strip club
because that's where the men went to
have business lunches and my male
colleague didn't really want me to come
so he said we're going to the strip club
and I assume you won't come I went
because I couldn't be scared off of my
job we turned into very good colleagues
over time because it turned out he was
afraid of me
he was afraid the MBA would take away
his job I had a boss introduced me as
this is Carly your new boss she's our
token bimbo I've been called all kinds
of names my appearance has been
commented on here's the truth it's
different when you're different
it is the criticism is different the
challenges are different and yet for
every thoughtless clueless careless
person in any organization in my
experience there are ten times as many
people who are well-meaning who want to
lift people up the problem is too often
the well-meaning people don't say
anything and so the bad behavior
continues and we've seen a lot of that
in the press as well
I mean Harvey Weinstein picture Matt
Lauer Harvey Weinstein the gymnastics
coach people knew that was going on and
they didn't do anything about it so
what's the best way for for women to
deal with that or anybody who's being
mistreated at work because one of the
things that we see is obviously I
totally agree people who do this sort of
stuff should be called out not only is
my mom working when my mom actually
worked my dad's stay at home my wife as
people know as a doctor so she's a
working woman what's the best way for
folks to deal with this because on the
one hand you want to call things out
when you see them on the other hand
there's there's a converse sort of
tendency for some people anyway to hide
behind the eight-ball of victimhood to
feel like there's so much there's so
much opposite there's such an obstacle
to overcome that I can never overcome it
and defeat themselves in the process
what's the best way to deal with with
these situations well the truth is it
depends on the situation so I'll tell
you two stories the guy who said we're
gonna go to the strip club to have lunch
right who was doing it obviously
purposefully to humiliate me and scare
me it almost worked
that he and I became great colleagues we
never talked about that day again
because the truth is I actually needed
to work with him he knew the clients he
knew the company and he figured out he
needed to work with me because he was
kind of a pie in the sky guy and I would
work hard and understand the details and
get it done so we became good colleagues
we worked our way through it the boss
who introduced me as a token bimbo I
went into his office afterwards shut the
door and said you will never speak to me
that way again
sometimes behavior has to be confronted
sometimes you have to realize that
someone was thoughtless and careless and
clueless and get over it and what I tell
young women young people of all kinds
but young women especially is my advice
is don't get a chip on your shoulder
there are bad people and bad people need
to be confronted but most people aren't
there may be thoughtless or clueless so
don't get a chip on your shoulder and
look for the people who will lift you up
because there are plenty of people who
will men and women but also don't hide
your light under a bushel
don't try and fit in don't be less smart
than you are be as smart as you are be
as brave as you are
be as tough as you are and if somebody
has a problem with that it's their
problem don't ever let it be your
problem
I mean what's really inspiring about
this sort of stuff I think is that it's
very individually based stuff it's not
stuff where you're calling for now we
have to call for a giant piece of
legislation a big piece of social change
it's just stand up for yourself in the
moment and and by the way the other
thing that I think is going on you
talked about victimhood and when people
feel victimized they feel helpless and
powerless and one of the reasons I wrote
this book is because actually all of us
have enormous power we just don't
realize it sometimes and we don't
realize how to unlock it and to use it
but the other thing that I worry about
in this current climate of me too is
everything is the same and everything
isn't the same a gymnast coach of
gymnasts who is abusing them routinely
or a Matt Lauer or Harvey Weinstein it's
not the same as Joe Biden
his hands on someone's shoulders you
can't create a situation where the real
issues become trivialized by people
saying I felt slightly uncomfortable so
what do you think let's take the Joe
Biden thing for example what do you
think the proper response both on the
part of Joe Biden and a society should
be to the sort of Joe Biden said I
totally agree with you by the way I
think that the failure of society to
recognize gradations in behavior to
suggest okay well this is a bad thing
and therefore all bad things are
equivalent bad things is really silly
and that's why I've said that the
attempt to paint Joe Biden as some sort
of great sexual victimizer when there's
not been a single allegation that he was
sexually victimizing anyone is bizarre
um but but how shouldn't society deal
with that sort of thing what should its
attitude be toward the Joe Biden's of
the world when they do this well I think
a lot of people have come to the
conclusion that this is silly this is
silly and a lot of people have said this
is silly a lot of women have said this
is silly both Democratic women and
Republican women I think really what the
Joe Biden episode illustrates is it's
politics and one of the things that I
think is unfortunate about politics is
that vitriol we talked about that tribal
I win you lose it's infecting every
conversation it's a shame when we can't
have a serious conversation about real
assault and real abuse because our
headlines are filled with what do we
think about Joe Biden that's all about
politics and it's all about his primary
opponents trying to take him down early
that's what that's about okay so in a
second I'm gonna ask you one final
question I want to ask you about whether
you think that the American people are
ready for a female president which is
one of the questions that has been in
the air since Hillary Clinton since you
ran but if you want to hear Carly
fiorina's answer you have to be a daily
wire subscriber to subscribe go to daily
wire comm click the subscribe button you
can hear the end of our conversation
there hardly for you to thanks so much
for stopping by it really is a pleasure
to see you it's great to be with you
thank you
[Music]
eventually rose shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis clubber edited by
Donovan Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan
Kate's hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera title graphics by Cynthia and
Guillot the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
[Music]